donc moi je crois que la meilleure
réalisation vraiment un peu ça a été sa
rigueur financière
je pense que non seulement est ce qu'on
va enlever un déficit zéro bientôt mais
il ya pu résister par exemple pu
résister d'augmenter les prestations
d'assurance chômage
même quand une grande pression pour le
faire insulter récession malgré que je
crois que il aurait pu aller beaucoup
plus loin et je suis jamais identifie
une grosse lacune du gouvernement ça a
été de jamais cherché à éliminer la
gestion de l'offre
on ne réalise pas ce que on paie deux
fois plus qu'on devrait pour le produit
laitier à cause d'un cartel qui qui
maintient les prix élevés mais c'est un
groupe d'intérêts tellement concentré
puis 5 j'imagine que le maroc peut
décider de ça valait pas la peine donc
après toutes ces années de grenoble
peuple est ce que je me sens davantage à
ma place au canada je crois que c'est
pas un gouvernement ou un autre qui va
changer c'est quoi mon identité
canadienne
mais il reste que je dois mettre quand
je voyage je me défendre un peu ces
politiques et je suis fier que souvent
ils s'allient port avec tous les autres
pays qui fait des fois à sa propre
taille puis je trouve que c'est
peut-être pas très canadien mais moi ça
me semble la carène